I've had a bunch of bike accidents in the last year and a half. And the moment that things go wrong is always the same. These accidents happen during my morning commute. And they always happen when it rains.
过去一年半里，我出过好几次自行车事故。而且每次出事的时候，情况总是如出一辙。这些事故都发生在我早晨通勤的路上。而且总是在下雨天发生。
I have this very light bicycle I got. And when it rains, something about this bike on the city streets-- a metal grate, a slippery patch of any sort at all, can make the bike slip out from under me. I have broken a clavicle. I banged up my wrist. I've given myself some kind of bruise on my right arm that still wakes me up at night, months later.
我有一辆非常轻的自行车。下雨时，这种车在城市道路上总会出现些状况——比如金属栅栏，或者任何湿滑的地方，都可能让车子从我脚下打滑溜走。我摔断过锁骨，手腕受过伤，右臂还磕出过淤青，几个月过去了，半夜还会疼醒。
And in each of these three accidents-- you know, like, when you're falling, there's that second or two when you realize you're going down, and you're on your way down, but you haven't actually hit the ground yet? Weirdly, it is enough time for a bunch of thoughts to go through your head. And all three times, like I say, it's been the same. Somehow I get very calm and I think, oh, this isn't going to be so bad. I'm not going very fast. The ground isn't that far. Is a car coming? OK, no car is coming. I figured out how to fall. It's going to be fine-- this time.
在每一次事故中——你知道，当你要摔倒时，会有那一两秒钟的时间意识到自己要倒了，虽然身子在下坠，但还没真正着地。奇怪的是，这段时间足够让你脑子里闪过很多念头。正如我所说，三次事故的情况都一模一样。不知怎么的，我变得非常冷静，心里想着：哦，应该不会太严重。我骑得又不快。离地面也不远。有车过来吗？好吧，没有车。我知道该怎么摔。这次会没事的。
And I think everybody knows how a person reacts under duress, it can tell you something about them. And I think what this set of thoughts says about me is I am optimistic even when there is no factual basis for it at all. Like, at the exact moment when I'm going to collide with the wet surface of the street, a moment when things are definitely not going to be fine, I'm thinking, things will be fine.
我觉得每个人都知道一个人在压力下的反应能反映出他的性格。我觉得这一连串的念头反映出即便在没有任何事实依据的情况下，我依然是个乐观主义者。就像在我即将撞向湿滑路面的那一刻，在那件注定会糟糕透顶的关头，我却在想：一切都会好起来的。
I think this optimism has kept me in faltering relationships. When I mentioned all this at our radio show story meeting this week, one of my coworkers, somebody who I've worked with closely for years, told me-- he has never said this-- that he thinks my optimism is the single most important quality I have. He said he'll tell me there are 17 things that can go wrong with some plan that we have. And I'll just go, eh, let's go for it. Though I have to say, after three accidents, I have learned not to ride this particular bike in the rain. Thank you very much.
我想正是这种乐观精神让我陷入了一些不顺的感情关系。本周在我们广播节目的选题会上提到这些事时，一位和我共事多年的同事告诉我——他以前从没说过——他认为我的乐观是我身上最重要的特质。他说他会列出我们的某个计划里可能出错的17个环节。而我只会说：“哎，咱们干吧。”不过我得说，在经历了三次事故后，我已经学会了不要在雨天骑这辆车了。非常感谢。
Today on our program, we have stories where things go very, very badly for people. They are on the way down and in that moment of crisis. What they're thinking reveals so much about who they are. Some people, it leads to new insights. Some, it leads to no insights at all. And some are hit with a lightning bolt of inspiration and figure out how to save themselves. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目中，有一些关于人们境遇极其糟糕的故事。他们正处于坠落和危机的时刻。他们的想法揭示了他们到底是怎样的人。对一些人来说，这带来了新的见解。对另一些人，则毫无启发。还有些人得到了灵感的火花，找到了自救的方法。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Pirates of the Cari-BEAN-TOWN." One summer, a while back, a group of friends got in trouble, got in over their heads, almost literally, in the middle of Boston Harbor. Our producer, Ike Sriskandarajah, tells the tale-- though, for the purposes of today's story, call him Ishmael.
第一幕，“波士顿加勒比海盗”。很久以前的一个夏天，一群朋友在波士顿港中间遇到了麻烦，几乎被淹没。我们的制作人艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾讲述了这个故事——不过，为了今天节目的需要，就叫他“以实玛利”吧。
I've been friends with you this whole time and I didn't know that this is your most told story.
我和你做了这么久的朋友，竟然不知道这是你讲得最多的故事。
Well, I wouldn't tell it to you. You were there.
嗯，我不会讲给你听的。你当时就在现场。
I was there. It was over 10 years ago and I was a new resident in the Boston area. My good friend, Sophie Tintori, introduced me to some people she knew well. We liked the same kinds of jokes and could only afford the same kind of rent. So we moved into a big house together. And soon, we got to the stage in any relationship where someone suggests taking things to the next level.
我确实在场。那是十多年前的事了，我刚搬到波士顿地区。我的好朋友索菲·廷托里把我介绍给她认识的朋友们。我们喜欢同样的笑话，而且只能负担得起同样的租金。于是我们搬进了一栋大房子里。很快，我们的关系发展到了那种有人提议要把事情提升到一个新层面的阶段。
So I don't know exactly how it came up, but maybe eight friends or so decided to go in, collectively, and buy a used boat. And to my understanding, none of them knew a single thing about boats.
我不知道具体是怎么提出来的，但大概有八个朋友决定合伙买了一艘二手船。据我所知，他们中间没一个人懂船。
True. But did you know the word "catamaran" comes from Tamil? Kattu maram, "wood tied together." Those are my guys. So that's one thing I know about boats. And maybe more ancestral knowledge was just waiting to surface if I owned a boat.
没错。但你知道“双体船”（catamaran）这个词来自泰米尔语吗？“Kattu maram”，意思是“绑在一起的木头”。那才是我的族人。所以这是我知道关于船的一件事。也许只要我拥有了一艘船，更多的祖传知识就会浮现出来。
Here's how it happened. Our friend Max brought us the opportunity. He knew a person who knew a person who needed to get rid of their boat. For $400 each, Max could make us Massachusetts boat people. Having double that in my bank account, I signed a check, sight unseen. And when I finally got to meet our boat down at the harbor, it felt like we had gotten away with larceny.
事情是这样的。我们的朋友马克斯提供了这个机会。他认识一个人，那人正好要处理掉自己的船。每人出400美元，马克斯就能让我们成为马萨诸塞州的“船民”。我的银行账户里有两倍的钱，于是我连船都没看就签了支票。当我最终在港口看到我们的船时，感觉就像我们合伙干了一票“偷窃”得手了。
I wish you could have seen it, a 1950s Hiliner, a glamorous little wooden motorboat with an engine hanging off the back, polished wood, two rows of white vinyl seats, chrome finishes. Think Italian vacation, like The Talented Mr Ripley, but right here on the Boston Riviera. Also, like Boston's own Matt Damon in The Talented Mr Ripley, a new high-society life was waiting for us.
真希望你们能看到它，那是一艘1950年代的“Hiliner”，一艘迷人的小型木制摩托艇，后面挂着引擎，打磨光亮的木头，两排白色乙烯基座椅，铬合金装饰。想象一下意大利度假，就像《天才瑞普利》里的场景，但就在波士顿的里维埃拉。而且，就像《天才瑞普利》里波士顿本地的马特·达蒙一样，一种新的上流社会生活正在等着我们。
The first time I got on the boat, it really felt like magic. We honked just the right number of times and a bridge opened up for us like a bouncer unclipping a red velvet rope to the VIP section. We entered the Charles River and stopped to admire the sailboats swirling around us.
第一次坐上这艘船时，感觉真的很神奇。我们按了刚好次数的喇叭，一座桥就像门卫解开贵宾区的红色丝绒绳一样为我们打开了。我们进入了查尔斯河，停下来欣赏周围盘旋的帆船。
A small motorboat pulled up to us. The man asked if we were stranded.
一艘小型摩托艇靠近了我们。那人问我们是不是搁浅了。
No, sir, just enjoying this beautiful day. Thanks for asking.
没有，先生，只是在享受这美好的一天。谢谢关心。
Well, you know, you're parked in the middle of a regatta.
嗯，你们知道吗，你们停在赛艇比赛的中间了。
Oh.
哦。
He looked us over. Do you guys work for Google?
他打量了我们一番。你们是在谷歌工作吗？
The plan to cosplay our way to high society was already working.
我们伪装成上流社会的计划已经初见成效了。
Max knew the next step. We had to announce our old boat as the newest member of Boston's watery glitterati, which meant a christening party. Max had been practicing for this moment his whole life. The man loves extravagant gestures.
马克斯知道下一步该怎么做。我们必须宣布我们的旧船成为波士顿水上名流圈的最新成员，这意味着要举办一场下水礼。马克斯一生都在为这一刻做准备。这家伙热爱浮夸的姿态。
He invited friends from near and far to the Charles River Esplanade and asked everyone to wear white. He showed up in black, a rented black tuxedo. Max stood on the front of the boat, named it Marjorie, after his own mother, and smashed a purple bottle of Andre sparkling wine on the nose.
他邀请了远近的朋友来到查尔斯河滨海艺术中心，并要求大家穿白色的衣服。他自己却穿了一身黑，一套租来的黑色燕尾服。马克斯站在船头，以他母亲的名字命名它为“玛乔丽号”，并用一瓶紫色的安德烈起泡酒砸向船头。
Now I don't know if you believe in curses, and we didn't know it right away, but Max invoked roughly three curses in that moment. Wearing a black tuxedo to a white party of your own design, that's more of a faux pas, not a curse. But number one, renaming a boat, that's a curse. Number two, Jews like Max don't name children after living relatives. Now, the prohibition doesn't specify boats, so let's call that a half curse. Number three, smashing champagne on a used boat-- I heard that's a curse, but only if you consider Andre sparkling wine to be champagne.
我不知道你们信不信诅咒，我们当时并不知道，但马克斯在那一刻引发了大约三个诅咒。在自己设计的白色派对上穿黑色燕尾服，那更像是失礼，而不是诅咒。但第一，重命名船只是一种诅咒。第二，像马克斯这样的犹太人不会用在世亲人的名字来命名孩子。现在，禁令里没明确提到船，所以就算半个诅咒吧。第三，用香槟砸旧船——我听说那也是一种诅咒，但前提是你得把安德烈起泡酒当成香槟。
Now it's impossible to say which curse attached itself to the Marjorie. But moments later, the sky darkened and we all scattered as sheets of rain fell upon us.
现在很难说到底是哪个诅咒附在了“玛乔丽号”上。但片刻之后，天空变暗了，雨点倾盆而下，我们四散奔逃。
The next day, the clouds cleared. Our friends were still in town so we tried to take them out again. Now this is where the story really begins.
第二天，云层散去。我们的朋友还在城里，所以我们又试着带他们出去。故事从这里才真正开始。
It was a beautiful day. I think it was early summer and really sunny and gorgeous. And there were maybe 12-- 12 of us on the boat? Does that sound right?
那是美好的一天。我想是初夏，阳光明媚，景色绚丽。我们船上大概有12个人吧？听起来对吗？
Nine in a boat that was maybe made for six. But our captain, Max, had just completed a boat safety course. And he told us the only limit for boat capacity is having enough life jackets for everyone, which isn't true. But we didn't know that and Max denies ever saying it. Squished together, two in the front seat, four in the back, three others perched on the sides, we headed out.
九个人挤在大概只能坐六个人的船里。但我们的船长马克斯刚完成了一个船只安全课程。他告诉我们，船只载客量的唯一限制是每个人都有救生衣，其实这根本不是真的。但我们不知道，马克斯也否认说过这话。挤在一起，前排坐两个，后排坐四个，另外三个蹲在边上，我们出发了。
People are taking turns driving, which is really fun. I got to take the wheel for a little bit. And I was cutting across the waves, in a way, where we'd like catch a little bit of air and slam down and catch some air and slam down, which I thought was very fun. And then at one point, somebody leaned over and said to me, Sophie, this is a wooden lake boat.
大家轮流驾驶，这真的很开心。我有一小会儿握住了方向盘。我以某种方式切开波浪，我们感觉像飞起了一点点，然后猛地落下，又飞起，又落下，我觉得这很有趣。然后有一次，有人俯身对我说：索菲，这是一艘木制的湖泊船。
The Marjorie wasn't built for high-octane thrills. Someone says, we should get back soon. But Sophie overrules them. And then, just like the American munitions that rebelled British ships in these very waters-- cannonball!
“玛乔丽号”不是为高强度的刺激而建造的。有人说：“我们应该早点回去。”但索菲否决了他们。然后，就像当年在这些水域反抗英国船只的美国弹药一样——炮弹入水！
I jump off the boat because it's a beautiful day and I like to swim. And I'm messing around and looking at the boat from the water. And when I climbed back into the boat, I climbed in on the back and I just hoisted myself up over the edge of the boat. And at the point where the most force was being pushed down on the boat, a whole grip of water just flowed right in.
我从船上跳下去，因为那天天气很好，我喜欢游泳。我胡乱游着，从水里看着船。当我爬回船上时，我从后方爬上去，把自己吊在船缘上。就在我用力压向船身的时候，一大股水直接涌了进来。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I'm like, whoa. OK.
我当时想：哇哦。好吧。
The back of the boat dipped below the waterline and Boston Harbor began to enter.
船尾沉到了水线以下，波士顿港的海水开始灌进来。
And then, almost instantaneously, the boat was thigh deep in water.
然后，几乎瞬间，船里水深已经没过大腿。
This is Ben Ewen Campen, a moral pillar of our group, the kind of friend your mom might ask, is Ben going to be at the party? We lived together and co-owned this boat.
这是本·尤恩·坎彭，我们团队的道德支柱，那种你妈妈可能会问“本也会去参加派对吗”的朋友。我们住在一起，共同拥有这艘船。
My memory is that it was really, really fast. Just it went from regular life, you're having fun, to all of a sudden, emergency mode.
我的记忆里，那一切发生得非常、非常快。只是从正常生活、玩得很开心，突然就到了紧急状态。
It's still a lovely summer day. We're still on our beautiful boat. But suddenly, I'm tearing an aluminum can in half to bail us out. Turns out, half a soda can only scoops as much water as your own cupped hands.
那天依然是个可爱的夏日。我们仍然在美丽的船上。但突然间，我正在撕开一个铝罐用来往外舀水。结果证明，半个汽水罐舀出的水和用双手捧水没什么两样。
I look over at Sophie, the most MacGyvery of us, to see if she has a better idea.
我看向索菲，我们中最像“百战天龙”的人，看看她有没有更好的主意。
I saw a empty gallon, plastic water gallon. And I was like, oh, if I could tear the top off of this, then I can scoop water out really fast. But I'm wondering-- I'm like, OK, I don't have anything to cut it with. That's fine. I'll cut it with my teeth. I'll just crack a little hole. And once I get a little hole going, there'll be purchase and I can tear the whole thing open.
我看到一个空的加仑塑料水桶。我就想：哦，如果我能把顶部撕掉，就能很快把水舀出去。但我在想——好吧，我没有什么东西可以割开它。没关系。我用牙咬。只要钻一个小孔，有了着力点，我就能把它整片撕开。
And I try to bite it with my teeth and my teeth are just so weak. And my hands are so weak. And I can't-- I can't do anything. I don't think I'm feeling-- experiencing anxiety. But suddenly, it's like one of those nightmares where none of your limbs work.
我试着用牙去咬它，我的牙太软了。我的手也使不上劲。我什么都做不了。我不觉得我在——经历焦虑。但突然间，这就像那些四肢都不听使唤的噩梦之一。
Maybe the weight of nine passengers was too much. Or maybe Sophie's full-throttle aerials had split the seams. Or maybe (WHISPERING) it was a curse.
也许九个人的重量太重了。或者是因为索菲全速行驶时的特技动作把缝隙撑裂了。又或者（低语）那是个诅咒。
Here's what we know. We're alone. We're in a small boat. We're far from shore. The nearest land to us is Logan Airport. And that's when it begins to dawn on me. If we have to jump off this boat and swim to the closest land, we would be army crawling up the banks of a government-controlled airspace.
我们只知道这些。我们孤立无援。我们在一条小船上。我们离岸很远。离我们最近的陆地是洛根机场。这时我开始意识到。如果我们必须跳下船游到最近的陆地，我们就得在政府管辖的领空边界上匍匐爬行。
Look, it's so close we can just swim to Logan. And very quickly and quietly, but quite definitively, you said, I'm not going to do that.
你看，离得那么近，我们可以直接游到洛根机场。你很快且安静，但相当明确地说：我才不去那儿。
I'm picturing my white friends being wrapped in tinfoil blankets and fed cocoa, and me being perp walked off the tarmac by Homeland Security. Not today, government black site.
我想象着我的白人朋友被裹在锡箔毯子里喝着热可可，而我却被国土安全部的人押出停机坪。今天不行，政府黑点。
Our options are shrinking. Our bails aren't bailing. The engine's not turning. There's water, water everywhere. I think we're going to sink.
我们的选择越来越少。我们的舀水工具不管用。引擎也转不动了。到处都是水。我想我们要沉了。
We were sinking. We were in a sinking boat.
我们在沉没。我们在一艘下沉的船上。
Toby David is visiting from Philly. A gifted speech maker, he helped christen the Marjorie just the day before. Now he reminds us he is not a good swimmer, asthmatic, and does not like cold water.
托比·大卫是从费城来拜访的。他是一位有天赋的演说家，前一天还帮着给“玛乔丽号”洗礼。现在他提醒我们，他游泳不好，有哮喘，而且不喜欢冷水。
The boat is going down and it's tilting. And we're in the middle of the water and we have no idea what to do. And I'm freaking out. I'm really fully freaking out.
船在下沉，正在倾斜。我们处在水中央，根本不知道该怎么办。我吓坏了。我是真的完全吓坏了。
I'm not hearing much. But through the ether, Ben's voice comes through and says, is anybody else noticing that occasionally one of us will ask a question and nobody will respond?
我听不太清。但透过以太，传来了本的声音，他说：还有人注意到吗，偶尔我们中间会有人问个问题，却没人回应？
A silent panic falls over us. It is a moment that demands leadership, decisive action. We turn our heads to our captain, Max. He found this boat, named it after his mother, sold us on the dream. And now, like a monomaniacal Ahab in a Red Sox cap, Max denies there's any problem at all.
一阵沉默的恐慌笼罩了我们。这是一个需要领导力、果断行动的时刻。我们将目光转向我们的船长马克斯。他找来了这条船，以他母亲的名字命名它，推销给我们这个梦想。而现在，就像戴着红袜队棒球帽的偏执狂亚哈船长，马克斯否认有任何问题。
When we were all wondering what to do, one element of it was everyone saying, should we call for help? And Max saying no. Max had this really strong instinct. Don't call for help. Don't call. I know what I'm doing.
当我们都在想该怎么办时，其中一个元素就是大家都在问：我们要不要呼救？而马克斯说不。马克斯有一种非常强烈的直觉。别呼救。别打。我知道我在做什么。
I think Max was trying to cover up for this massive fuck up. And so he was sort of in denial that there was a problem.
我认为马克斯是在试图掩盖这个巨大的烂摊子。所以他处于一种否认有问题的状态。
Even up to the point where the entire back end of the boat was fully underwater, the entire motor was underwater, Max was still saying it's fine, there's no problem.
即使在船尾完全没入水下，整个引擎也进了水的时候，马克斯依然在说“没事的，没问题”。
But there are two. One, we're stranded in the water. And two, our captain has gone mad. We only know how to deal with the last one. Everyone shouts at Max. Admit it. We are in trouble. You need to call for help. But Max is sitting in the captain's seat, one hand clenched around the steering wheel and the other turning the key in the ignition, like the engine wasn't underwater. The expression "hope floats?" Not true and very dangerous.
但问题有两个。第一，我们被困在水里了。第二，我们的船长疯了。我们只知道如何处理第二个问题。每个人都对马克斯大喊。承认吧。我们有麻烦了。你需要呼救。但马克斯坐在船长位上，一只手紧紧握住方向盘，另一只手在点火装置上转动钥匙，就像引擎没进水一样。“希望会浮起来？”这是假的，而且非常危险。
On one end of the spectrum of willingness to acknowledge this situation, there was Max, who was just face forward, pretending he was still driving a boat. And then at the other end of the spectrum, the other extreme, was there was-- there was this one wild card.
在承认这种局面的意愿谱系的一端，是马克斯，他只是目视前方，假装他还在驾驶船。而在谱系的另一端，另一个极端，是——出现了一个变数。
Cath-- oh, my god. I don't know anything about her.
凯丝——天哪。我对她一无所知。
She just sort of appeared in a beam of clarity.
她就在一道清晰的光束中出现了。
Cath Spangler went to college with Max. She is the ninth passenger and the one outsider. When Max invited her on a ride, he had not mentioned there would be so many of us. For most of the trip, she was shy and off to the side. But now the strangers surrounding her are screaming at the one person she knows. And he has lost control.
凯丝·斯潘格勒和马克斯是大学同学。她是第九位乘客，也是唯一的局外人。当马克斯邀请她来搭船时，没说会有这么多人。大部分时间她都很害羞，待在一旁。但现在，周围的陌生人都在对她唯一认识的人尖叫。而他已经失去了控制。
I remember, just really clearly, looking over at Max, sitting there in the captain's seat, with his eyes kind of downcast, frozen. And something-- there was a switch that flipped in me. If the boat sinks and all of us are in the harbor, we're no longer visible to anyone. We're just little heads. No one can see us. We can tread water for a while.
我记得很清楚，看向坐在船长位上的马克斯，他的眼睛有点低垂，僵住了。有什么东西——在我心里有个开关被拨动了。如果船沉了，我们所有人都掉进港口，我们就没法被任何人看见了。我们只是一个个小脑袋。我们只能踩水一会儿。
What if we get a cramp, get tired, swallow water? How long can we do that for? What if the current takes us out further? I didn't want to let myself go there, but I remember thinking that people were going to die. If we don't do something, people are going to die today.
如果我们抽筋了，累了，呛了水呢？我们能撑多久？如果海流把我们带向更远的地方呢？我不想让自己往那方面想，但我记得我当时在想，有人会死。如果我们不采取行动，今天会有人死。
And in that moment, Captain Cath is born.
就在那一刻，凯丝船长诞生了。
My mind went really blank and calm. And it was like a calculator filled my brain. And I was just very logical and I started focusing on actions. Where are the life vests? How many do you have? I took on this voice that was very bossy and direct.
我的头脑变得非常空白和冷静。就像大脑里装进了一台计算器。我变得非常理智，开始专注于行动。救生衣在哪？你有多少件？我用了一种非常专横和直接的语调。
Like Boston's own Matt Damon in Good Will Hunting, she begins solving the unsolvable problem. Namely, if nine passengers get in a boat which turns out to only have eight life jackets-- not one per person as we had been led to believe, Max-- and now some of those life jackets are unreachable in the underwater part of the boat, how many passengers are totally screwed?
就像波士顿本地的《心灵捕手》里的马特·达蒙，她开始解决无法解决的问题。即，如果九个乘客坐上一艘结果发现只有八件救生衣的船——并不是我们被误导的每人一件，马克斯——而且现在其中一些救生衣在船的水下部分拿不到，那么有多少乘客彻底完蛋了？
I remember looking over and there was this guy who looked really pale. He just didn't look like he was doing very well. And I asked him-- I said, can you swim well? And he said, no, I can't. And I just gave him the life vest. I took it off my neck, put it on his, and said, well, I can.
我记得看过去，有个家伙脸色很苍白。他看起来情况不太好。我问他——我说，你游泳游得好吗？他说，不，我游不好。于是我就把救生衣递给他。我把它从我脖子上摘下来，戴在他身上，说，好吧，我能游。
Cath hands out the remaining life jackets based on need. The water is rising. We are coming apart and preparing to abandon ship.
凯丝根据需要分配了剩余的救生衣。水位在上升。我们四分五裂，准备弃船。
And that's when I got on top of the bow of the boat.
就在那时，我爬到了船头。
She climbs to the front of the boat and starts waving her arms to the pilots in airplanes over our heads, to nearby boats in the water, anyone who might be able to come to our rescue.
她爬到船前，开始向我们头顶飞机上的飞行员挥舞双臂，向水里附近的船只挥舞，向任何可能前来营救我们的人挥舞。
She was the one person who was like, what the fuck is wrong with you people? Of course we need help.
她是唯一一个觉得“你们这些人到底怎么了？”的人。我们当然需要救助。
And she like stood up on the boat and started waving her arms and trying to get the attention of a boat that I didn't realize was also quite close, that was, like, the rescue boat.
她站在船上开始挥动双臂，试图吸引一艘我没意识到离得很近的船的注意，那是救援船。
An actual rescue boat just within waving distance.
一艘真正的救援船就在挥手距离之内。
It was so much taller than us, off the waterline. And there were guys on deck, kind of looking down and almost chuckling at us, making light of the situation. And I remember feeling like, they have no idea what we've been through.
它比我们高出很多，离开水面。甲板上有几个人，低头看着我们，甚至有点轻笑，轻视着这种局面。我记得当时的感觉是：他们根本不知道我们经历了什么。
They must have radioed for a tow boat because one arrives within minutes. The captain calls down, do I have permission to perform a life rescue?
他们一定是用无线电呼叫了拖船，因为几分钟内就到了一艘。船长在上面大喊：我有权执行生命救援吗？
Who says no to that?
谁会拒绝这个？
I have to confess one thing really fast.
我必须坦白一件事，很快。
Toby is admirably honest about what happened next.
托比对接下来发生的事情表现得非常诚实。
I just have to say, I'm sure that, when the rescue boat arrived, that I-- I may have been the first person off of the sinking ship. I fucking levitated to that ladder to get off that boat. So that's not great for me.
我必须说，我敢肯定，当救援船到达时，我——我可能是第一个离开那艘沉船的人。我该死的像漂浮一样冲向那个梯子，逃离那艘船。所以这对我的形象不太好。
We climbed off the boat to safety. And just like Matt Damon in Saving Private Ryan, we were going home. Cath says she looks back at this moment a lot, that it's become pivotal to her understanding of herself. She's proud that she jumped in and saved us.
我们爬上船脱离危险。就像《拯救大兵瑞恩》里的马特·达蒙一样，我们要回家了。凯丝说她经常回顾这一刻，这成了她理解自己的人生转折点。她为自己挺身而出救了我们而自豪。
It was a tragic ending for our captain. From the safety of our tow boat, I can still picture him down there, alone on the Marjorie, refusing to abandon ship. And that was the last time I ever saw him. He died that day.
对我们的船长来说，这是一个悲剧性的结局。从拖船的安全地带，我依然能想象他还在“玛乔丽号”上，拒绝弃船。那是我最后一次见到他。他那天死了。
Yeah, the only honorable thing I could have done. I went down with the ship.
是的，那是当时我唯一能做的光荣之事。我和船一起沉没了。
Captain Max died. My friend Max survived. A little bruised-- his ego and his reputation for big schemes with little consequences. And while the boat became the story Sophie likes to tell more than any other, not Max.
马克斯船长死了。我的朋友马克斯活了下来。受了点伤——他的自尊心，以及他那种代价很小的大计划的声誉。虽然这艘船成了索菲最喜欢讲的故事，但马克斯却不是。
This is a story I have told the least. I can't overstate to you how big a failure this was, one of the most embarrassing failures of my entire life. It's a thing I look back at and shudder.
这是我讲得最少的故事。我怎么强调也不为过，这是一次多么大的失败，是我一生中最尴尬的失败之一。这是一个我回顾时会颤抖的事情。
Max spent more than a decade feeling terrible. The rest of us spent that same amount of time wondering why our friend Max was trying to gaslight us and sink us. But we'd never talked about it. None of us have. And when Max and I catch up for this story, it becomes clear that he has a completely different memory of how it all went down. He says he actually did the one thing we were begging him to do.
马克斯花了十多年时间感觉糟糕透顶。我们其余的人花了同样长的时间想知道为什么我们的朋友马克斯试图对我们进行煤气灯操控（心理操控）并沉了我们的船。但我们从来没讨论过。我们谁也没说。当我和马克斯为了这个故事叙旧时，很明显，他对于事情是如何发生的，有着完全不同的记忆。他说他其实做了我们一直在乞求他做的那一件事。
I remember a lot of things. I remember calling Sea Tow and telling them where we were. I remember that--
我记得很多事情。我记得给Sea Tow打过电话，告诉他们我们在哪。我记得那——
Wait, can I just back up one sec?
等等，我可以倒退一下吗？
Go ahead.
请便。
Did you just say you called Sea Tow?
你刚才说你给Sea Tow打了电话？
Sea Tow is boat AAA, the boat that performed the life rescue. Max says he called them on his phone way back when the engine first stalled out. That's the reason we got saved that day.
Sea Tow是船只界的AAA（美国汽车协会），就是执行生命救援的那艘船。马克斯说他在引擎刚熄火时就用手机给他们打了电话。那就是我们那天获救的原因。
Yeah. I don't think I made a big deal about calling Sea Tow.
是的。我想我没大张旗鼓地说我打了Sea Tow的电话。
No. I didn't believe him. I just interviewed five of our friends who had no memory of this at all. So I followed up with Sea Tow. Turns out they keep meticulous records. And there it was, a call for a tow, July 17, 2010, charged to our membership under Max's name. It cost $50. Help was on the way. I guess in the chaos, Max just forgot to tell everybody on the boat.
不。我不相信他。我刚采访了五个朋友，他们对此毫无记忆。所以我跟踪采访了Sea Tow。结果发现他们保存了详尽的记录。果然有，一次拖船呼叫，2010年7月17日，以马克斯的名义记在了我们的会员账户下。花了50美元。救援正在路上。我想在混乱中，马克斯只是忘了告诉船上所有人。
Look, I-- clearly, I owe them an explanation. But a lot of our passive-aggressive-ass friends have never brought up this day with me.
看，我——显然，我欠他们一个解释。但我们那些被动攻击型（阴阳怪气）的朋友从来没和我提过那天的事。
Our story had hardened over a decade, but was built on a lie. Max had kind of done the right thing. And Cath wasn't the one who saved us. The sadistic editors at This American Life made me invite Cath back to share our findings.
我们的故事在十年间已经定型，但却是建立在一个谎言之上的。马克斯确实做了正确的事。而凯丝并不是救了我们的人。那些《美国生活》残忍的编辑让我把凯丝请回来分享我们的发现。
Max called for help. And apparently he was the one who got help to arrive, not you, waving.
马克斯呼救了。而且显然是他让救援到达的，不是你，在那儿挥手。
That just feels impossible.
这感觉简直不可能。
But I think it's true. And I'm so sorry that's the way that it happened.
但我认为是真的。我很抱歉事情是以那种方式发生的。
I'm just completely confused. So this whole time, he has been the hero of this story but no one has known it? It's so perfect that this is the finding. It's so unlike Max, too, to not claim that, claim the credit of it and say, no, I did that.
我彻底糊涂了。所以一直以来，他才是这个故事里的英雄，但没人知道？这个发现简直太完美了。也太不像马克斯了，竟然不去邀功，不把功劳据为己有。
The final curse on the Marjorie had the longest fuse and a devastating payload. It added an asterisk to a heroic deed and turned a failed captain into a guy who kind of did the right thing, but was really confusing about it. Please heed this precautionary tale. Beware of curses. Don't try to be a Massachusetts boat person for just $400. And if you already called Sea Tow, tell your friends.
“玛乔丽号”上的最后一个诅咒有着最长的引信和毁灭性的载荷。它给英雄事迹加了一个星号，把一个失败的船长变成了一个做了正确的事，却让人困惑的家伙。请以此为戒。小心诅咒。别试图只花400美元就成为马萨诸塞州的“船民”。如果你已经呼叫了Sea Tow，告诉你的朋友们。
(SINGING) Well, gather round and hear this tale, all you sons and daughters, of a cursed motor boat at the bottom of the Boston Harbor. Captain Max sold them on a dream of heading out to sea, you see. They emptied out their bank accounts and bought the Marjorie-re. Marjorie, Marjorie. They emptied out their bank accounts and bought the Marjorie.
（歌唱）来吧，聚在这里听这个故事，所有的儿子和女儿们，关于波士顿港底部一艘被诅咒的摩托艇。马克斯船长向他们推销去海上的梦想，你们看。他们掏空了银行账户，买了玛乔丽号。玛乔丽，玛乔丽。他们掏空了银行账户，买了玛乔丽。
Well, Captain Max was standing proud on that fateful morning, torso bare and the wind in his hair. Suddenly, without warning, the engine died, the children cried, and the ship filled up with water. Captain Max said, I'll see you all at the bottom of the Boston Harbor, in Davy Jones's locker.
好吧，马克斯船长在那个命运之日的早晨自豪地站着，光着上身，风吹动着他的头发。突然，毫无预兆，引擎熄灭，孩子们哭泣，船身灌满了水。马克斯船长说，我会在波士顿港的底部、在戴维·琼斯的储物柜里见到你们。
He said he'd never call for help, but did he anyhow? Or was it Cath that waved them down? We'll never find out now. Loose lips can sink this ship. Secrets never travel. Captain Max in his watery grave, how do you like them apples? Marjorie, Marjorie. Captain Max went down with his ship. How do you like them apples?
他说他永远不会求救，但他还是打了吗？或者是凯丝挥手把他们救下来的？我们现在永远不会知道了。多嘴会沉船。秘密永不传播。波士顿港底的马克斯船长，你喜欢这些苹果吗？玛乔丽，玛乔丽。马克斯船长和他的船一起沉没了。你喜欢这些苹果吗？
So that story was by Ike Sriskandarajah. The sea shanty was written for us by Sam Geller, who was there that fateful day. He is Captain Max's brother. He performs as Samson the Truest. Other writers in the song, Aeriel East, Chances with Wolves, and Glasser. Gordon Minette played the accordion.
刚才的故事是由艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾讲述的。这首海员号子是由萨姆·盖勒为我们写的，他就在那个命运之日也在现场。他是马克斯船长的兄弟。他以“最真实的萨姆森”为艺名表演。歌曲的其他创作者还有Aeriel East, Chances with Wolves 和 Glasser。戈登·米内特演奏了手风琴。
Coming up, ship gets a new captain who immediately throws half the crew overboard, he says, to save the ship from sinking. We hear an insider's true, real-life account. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，船换了一位新船长，他立刻把一半船员扔进了大海，他说，是为了拯救船只不沉没。我们要听听内部人士真实的生活叙述。稍后片刻，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, What I Was Thinking as We Were Sinking. We have stories today about what goes through your head in the middle of calamities, big and small, and what those thoughts tell us. We have arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, "Going Down With the Censorship."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是：当我们下沉时我在想什么。我们今天的故事讲述的是在灾难发生时（无论大小），你脑子里闪过的念头，以及这些念头告诉我们的事情。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“与审查制度同沉”。
So the SS Marjorie cost our producer Ike and his friends about $400 each. The ship we're going to talk about next is significantly more expensive by $44 billion. That's what Elon Musk paid for Twitter back in October. The company has been sort of famously foundering in the water since then.
所以，“玛乔丽号”让我们的制作人艾克和他的朋友们每人花费了大约400美元。接下来我们要讲的这艘“船”要昂贵得多，高达440亿美元。这就是埃隆·马斯克去年10月为推特支付的价格。从那时起，这家公司就像在水里出了名地搁浅了一样。
And some of the most revealing details about what it has been like on the inside at that company, among the people who work there, have come from reporter Casey Newton and his colleague, Zoe Schiffer. They make the newsletter, Platformer. They've had so many scoops.
关于在那家公司内部，在员工中是什么感觉，一些最揭露真相的细节来自于记者凯西·牛顿和他的同事佐伊·希弗。他们制作了时事通讯《Platformer》。他们有太多的独家新闻了。
Casey also co-hosts a podcast called Hard Fork that The New York Times puts out about the tech industry that, can I say, I love. Highest recommendation. But to get back to our story, there's been one person in particular at Twitter that Casey has been wanting to talk to, a very senior employee at the company who, while just doing his job, ended up having to take on two of the most powerful people on the internet and in the world. Those two people-- Elon Musk and the former President of the United States, Donald Trump.
凯西还共同主持了一档名为《Hard Fork》的播客，由《纽约时报》发布，关于科技行业，我可以再说一次，我超爱。强烈推荐。但回到我们的故事，推特有一个人是凯西一直想聊的，公司里一位级别很高的高管，他在执行自己的职责时，不得不应对互联网和世界上最强大的两个人。这两个人——埃隆·马斯克和前美国总统唐纳德·特朗普。
Casey wanted to hear all about that, and also what it was like for the guy, what he was thinking, what he was doing, once Elon took over and the place started taking on water. Here's Casey Newton.
凯西想听听关于那一切的故事，还有当埃隆接管后，这个地方开始进水时，那个人的感受，他在想什么，他在做什么。这是凯西·牛顿。
Yoel Roth did a lot of jobs at Twitter over the years, but it was always the same kind of job. He was in the content moderation business, one of those people who decides which of your posts can stay up on the internet and which ones need to come down. And he got his first glimpse at what life as a content moderator would be like while he was in college, on a date. He's gay. So am I.
尤尔·罗斯这些年来在推特做过很多工作，但始终是同一类工作。他从事的是内容审核业务，就是决定你的哪些帖子可以留在互联网上，哪些需要删除。他在大学约会时第一次窥见了内容审核员的生活是什么样的。他是同性恋。我也是。
I went out for drinks with somebody without knowing where he worked. And he volunteered that he actually worked for the parent company of the website Manhunt, which was one of the early gay websites that was very specifically sexually focused.
我和某人出去喝饮料，不知道他在哪里工作。他主动说他实际上为网站“Manhunt”的母公司工作，那是早期的同性恋网站之一，非常明确地专注于性内容。
And even in these early days of the web, there was already a team of people who were deciding what you could and couldn't post there.
即使在互联网早期，也已经有一支团队在决定你能和不能在那里发什么内容了。
They had a set of convoluted rules about what types of nudity you were allowed to show in which places. So nudity, fine, but not all nudity. So there were specifics. And he described to me a system of color-coding images, of red, yellow, green, and then a team of people who were responsible for making those designations.
他们有一套复杂的规则，关于你被允许在什么地方展示什么类型的裸露。所以裸露可以，但不是所有裸露都可以。所以有具体细节。他向我描述了一个对图像进行颜色编码的系统，红色、黄色、绿色，还有一支负责进行这些分类的团队。
And I'll never forget. He said, the people doing these reviews are almost entirely straight women. And I was just floored in that moment of thinking, God, there's a team of heterosexual women who have to look at the depraved things that gay men are posting on the internet? I'm so sorry. And--
我永远不会忘记。他说，做这些审核的人几乎全是异性恋女性。那一刻我简直震惊了，心想：天哪，有一群异性恋女性不得不去看同性恋者在互联网上发布的那些堕落东西？我真抱歉。而且——
Right, the senior hole pic specialist at Manhunt was some poor woman.
没错，“Manhunt”的高级私处照片专家竟然是个可怜的女人。
That's not an exaggeration.
这并不夸张。
Yeah, We hope she's doing OK. Are you out there? Call into This American Life.
是的，我们希望她一切都好。你在那儿吗？打电话给《美国生活》。
I'm so sorry.
我真的很抱歉。
I'm sorry for what you saw.
我对你所看到的一切感到抱歉。
After the date, Yoel had one thought.
约会结束后，尤尔只有一个想法。
I was like, aha, that's my dissertation topic.
我想：啊哈，那就是我的论文题目。
Yoel was in grad school. He got his PhD and, soon after, a job at Twitter. They gave him a small desk. This was 2015. The office's most striking feature was probably--
尤尔当时在读研究生。他拿到了博士学位，不久后在推特找到了一份工作。他们给了他一张小桌子。那是2015年。办公室里最显眼的特征可能是——
A giant, life-sized, cardboard cutout of Justin Bieber sat directly behind my desk.
一个巨大的、等身大的、贾斯汀·比伯的纸板人形立牌直接立在我的桌子后面。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Justin Bieber obviously being a major figure in early Twitter.
贾斯汀·比伯显然是早期推特上的一个重要人物。
Maybe the most popular user, at least for some period of time.
也许是当时最受欢迎的用户，至少在某段时间内。
Yes. There were rumors that Twitter had entire servers just dedicated to serving Justin Bieber-related traffic.
是的。有传言说推特有专门的服务器专门用于服务贾斯汀·比伯相关的流量。
Besides Bieber, what Twitter was really known for back then was its trolls. The site was plagued by users harassing other users, particularly women. That year, I co-reported a story about how the site's then-CEO, Dick Costolo, wrote a memo saying, quote, "We suck at dealing with abuse and trolls on the platform and we've sucked at it for years."
除了比伯，那时候推特真正出名的是它的喷子（trolls）。这个网站深受骚扰其他用户的用户困扰，尤其是针对女性。那一年，我参与报道了一个故事，讲述了该网站时任首席执行官迪克·科斯特洛写的一份备忘录，文中写道：“我们在处理平台上的滥用和喷子方面做得一塌糊涂，而且已经烂了很多年了。”
That was the backdrop for Yoel's new job. As an intern at Twitter the previous year, he spent part of his time moderating content. He'd seen this video of a dog getting abused. He removed it from the site, but for years, it haunted him.
这就是尤尔新工作的背景。作为推特的前实习生，他花了一些时间审核内容。他看过一段虐待狗的视频。他把它从网站上移除了，但多年来它一直萦绕在心头。
It was never even like the specific image. I couldn't-- I couldn't tell you what the dog looked like or what the video was. I just remember its existence. And I remember that feeling of seeing it and then of clicking-- I think the button said "No."
甚至从来不是那张具体的图片。我不能——我没法告诉你那只狗看起来什么样，或者那是什么视频。我只记得它的存在。我还记得看到它之后，然后点击——我想按钮上写着“不”。
More than anyone ever talks about, it's this mostly invisible job of content moderation that makes Twitter usable for the average person. It's what makes every forum on the internet usable at all. And Yoel was good at the job. He got promotion after promotion in his department, what Twitter and a lot of other tech companies now call Trust and Safety. It's a hard job. And it just kept getting more complicated.
比任何人谈论的都要多，正是这种大部分时间隐形的内容审核工作，让推特对普通人来说是可用的。这让互联网上的每一个论坛都真正可用。尤尔在这份工作中表现出色。他在部门里一次次晋升，现在的推特和其他许多科技公司将其称为“信任与安全”。这是一份艰苦的工作。而且它变得越来越复杂。
The way Yoel tells it, there was a wild new case to examine almost every day-- foreign governments impersonating their enemies, real people organizing harassment campaigns, impossible debates over what should count as hate speech, and regular meetings over whether to put labels on tweets that didn't quite violate the company's rules but would benefit from more context, like about COVID.
按照尤尔的说法，几乎每天都有一个疯狂的新案例需要审查——外国政府冒充敌方，真实的人组织骚扰活动，关于什么是仇恨言论的不可能辩论，以及关于是否给那些并不完全违反公司规则但会从更多背景信息中获益的推文（比如关于新冠的）打上标签的例行会议。
In 2020, the biggest case yet landed on Yoel's desk. It was a case about a user who kept causing problems. And this guy's fans were even more rabid than Justin Bieber's. It was the President of the United States, Donald Trump.
2020年，迄今为止最大的案例落在了尤尔的桌上。这是一个关于一位不断制造问题的用户的案例。而这个人的粉丝甚至比贾斯汀·比伯的粉丝还要疯狂。他是美国总统，唐纳德·特朗普。
This is a couple of months into the pandemic. Trump had tweeted that mail-in ballots in that year's election were going to lead to widespread fraud. And just to lay my own cards on the table, I thought that was really bad because they won't lead to widespread fraud.
那是疫情期间的几个月。特朗普发推文称当年的邮寄选票会导致大规模欺诈。为了摆明我的立场，我认为这非常糟糕，因为它们根本不会导致大规模欺诈。
Anyway, Twitter's policies prohibited misleading people about the voting process the way Trump was doing. But the company had never taken action against the president's tweets before. Yoel had to decide what to do.
总之，推特的政策禁止像特朗普那样在投票过程上误导他人。但该公司此前从未对总统的推文采取行动。尤尔必须决定怎么做。
I didn't see a basis for changing the policy, modifying it, winking at it, squinting and finding a violation-- there was no way around it. It was clearly a violation of our policy.
我没看到改变政策、修改它、给它暗示、眯着眼找违规的依据——没别的办法。这显然违反了我们的政策。
Truthfully, there was a lot of nervousness about crossing this line-- for the first time, taking action on a tweet from the President of the United States.
老实说，对于越过这条红线非常紧张——这是第一次对美国总统的推文采取行动。
The company decided that instead of removing the president's post, it would put a label under it, a label that just said, "Get the facts about mail-in ballots," with a link to a page that pushed back on Trump's claims.
公司决定不删除总统的帖子，而是在下面打上一个标签，标签上写着：“获取有关邮寄选票的事实”，并附上一个链接，指向一个反驳特朗普说法的页面。
At a certain point, when it became clear that yes, this was going to happen, it became a question of who could push the button.
在某一时刻，当情况变得清楚，没错，这件事真的要发生了，问题就变成了谁能按下那个按钮。
On some level, we probably understand that, in a moment like this, someone has to take a physical action to type the words, "Get the facts about mail-in ballots" and click the button to attach the label to the post. I've talked to dozens of content moderators over the years, but I've never talked to someone who had moderated the president of the United States.
在某种程度上，我们可能明白，在这种时刻，必须有人采取物理行动来键入“获取有关邮寄选票的事实”这几个字，并点击按钮将标签附加到帖子。多年来我采访过几十位内容审核员，但我从没采访过审核过美国总统的人。
When it came time to take action, only a handful of people at Twitter had the power to do it. The company had locked down access after an incident where a former contractor, on his last day working there, briefly deactivated Trump's account. Shout out to Bhatiyar Duysak, who says it was an accident. Also Twitter had just introduced this idea of putting labels on misinformation a couple of weeks before.
当采取行动的时候，推特只有少数几个人有权这样做。在发生过一次前承包商在最后一天短暂禁用了特朗普账户的事件后，公司锁定了访问权限。向巴蒂亚尔·杜萨克致敬，他说那是意外。此外，推特刚好在几周前引入了这个给误导性信息打标签的想法。
And so it was this perfect storm where it required elevated access and knowledge of this incredibly convoluted system for applying these labels. And I was the only one who knew how to do it. And so I got an instruction from my boss that said, all right, we're going to do this.
所以这是个完美的风暴，它需要高级权限和对这套极其复杂的应用标签系统的知识。而只有我一个人知道怎么做。于是我收到了老板的指令，他说：“好吧，我们要这么做。”
Also, because this is how life goes, Yoel and his husband were moving houses the day all this happened.
此外，因为生活总是这样，尤尔和他的丈夫在这一切发生的那天刚好要搬家。
I excused myself from wrangling the dog and the movers and the relocation of stuff, and sat in the front seat of the car with my cell phone tethered to my work laptop. I was on a video call with some of the other leaders at the company who were making this decision. And I remember a countdown where I was going to push the button that would apply the label to this tweet.
我向处理狗和搬家工人以及物品搬迁的人请了个假，坐在车的前排，手机连着工作笔记本电脑。我和公司其他几位做出这一决定的领导人在视频通话。我还记得有个倒计时，我将按下按钮，给那条推文加上标签。
At that same moment, Twitter's communications staff was going to announce the decision.
就在同一时间，推特的公关人员将宣布这一决定。
And it felt very important, in that moment, for the timing to be exactly joined up for some reason. We counted down. I clicked the button. And then I refreshed the public view of the tweet and saw the label. And the Communications team said, we've got it from here. And I said, OK, I have to go back and deal with the movers now. And I hung up the call and I closed my laptop. And I crossed the street, back into my apartment.
那一刻，出于某种原因，时机配合得非常精准感觉非常重要。我们倒数。我点击了按钮。然后我刷新了推文的公开页面，看到了标签。公关团队说：“接下来的交给我们。”我说：“好吧，我得回去处理搬家工人的事了。”我挂了电话，合上了笔记本电脑。我穿过街道，回到了我的公寓。
If they made a movie about Trump and Twitter, you can imagine how they'd shoot this scene, with the Twitter employees hunched over a console in a control room, high-fiving. But in reality, of course, it's the opposite. Most content moderators try really hard not to bring their own political beliefs into the job. In a way, the legitimacy of the whole company they work for depends on it.
如果他们拍一部关于特朗普和推特的电影，你可以想象他们会如何拍摄这一幕，推特员工弓着身子围着控制室的操作台，击掌庆祝。但实际上，当然，恰恰相反。大多数内容审核员非常努力地不把自己的政治信仰带入工作中。在某种程度上，他们所服务的整个公司的合法性取决于此。
Shortly before that Trump tweet, Twitter had explained its reasoning for adding labels to misleading information with a blog post. Importantly, the post was signed with Yoel's name. But soon after that first label showed up on Trump's tweet, his name was everywhere.
在那条特朗普推文之前不久，推特通过一篇博客文章解释了添加标签以防误导性信息的原因。重要的是，文章署名是尤尔的名字。但在那第一个标签出现在特朗普推文上之后不久，他的名字就随处可见了。
I wake up one morning, the third day that my husband and I are in our new home, to my phone exploding because Kellyanne Conway has just talked about me on Fox News and has said that I'm responsible for the censorship of the president's account and am responsible for censorship at Twitter, more generally. And in that moment, everything exploded.
一天早上醒来，那是我和丈夫搬进新家的第三天，我的手机炸开了锅，因为凯莉安·康威刚在福克斯新闻上谈到我，说我是总统账户审查的始作俑者，并要对推特上更广泛的审查负责。那一刻，一切都爆发了。
Thank you very much. We're here today to defend free speech from one of the gravest dangers--
非常感谢。我们今天在这里保卫言论自由，对抗最严重的危险之一——
The president held up a copy of The New York Post, with me on it, in the Oval Office as he announced an executive order restricting censorship by Silicon Valley companies.
总统在椭圆形办公室举起了一份《纽约邮报》，上面有我的照片，他宣布了一项行政命令，限制硅谷公司的审查制度。
His name is Yoel Roth. And he's the one that said that mail-in balloting-- you look-- mail-in-- no fraud. No fraud, really?
他的名字叫尤尔·罗斯。就是他说邮寄选票——你看——邮寄——没有欺诈。没有欺诈，真的吗？
And for weeks, discussion of me and my political opinions and my beliefs became a symbol of everything that was allegedly wrong with Silicon Valley and with the decisions that companies have made.
几周来，关于我和我的政治观点及信仰的讨论成了所谓硅谷所有错误，以及公司所做决定的象征。
Twitter had to hire security to protect Yoel and his husband. It had all taken him by surprise. He'd expected the criticism, but not that he would be the target. In cases like this, people would usually come after the CEO or the company itself. But soon, Yoel realized that what his harassers were doing was much more effective.
推特不得不雇佣保安来保护尤尔和他的丈夫。这一切都让他措手不及。他预料到了批评，但没料到自己会成为目标。在这种情况下，人们通常会攻击CEO或公司本身。但很快，尤尔意识到骚扰者所做的要有效得多。
If you make companies believe that their employees could be hurt for enforcing the rules, they might be more reluctant to enforce them. Twitter didn't stop though. They kept putting labels on his tweets. And Trump, of course, lost the election-- though that's probably not how he would describe what happened. And after the January 6 attacks at the Capitol, he lost his Twitter account too. Yoel did not press the button on that one, but here's a detail about that day that I love.
如果你让公司相信他们的员工可能因执行规则而受到伤害，他们执行规则的意愿可能会减弱。不过推特没停止。他们继续给他的推文打标签。特朗普当然输掉了选举——尽管那可能不是他描述发生的事情的方式。在1月6日的国会山袭击事件后，他也失去了他的推特账户。尤尔没按那个按钮，但我爱那天的一个细节。
Yeah, there was a technical question about whether it would work or whether Twitter would crash.
是的，当时有个技术问题，关于它是否会奏效，或者推特是否会崩溃。
Can you actually ban Donald Trump's account--
你们真的能封禁唐纳德·特朗普的账户吗——
Banning somebody with that many followers is actually technically very complicated. When you suspend somebody, Twitter systems have to figure out what to do with all of the people who followed them. And--
封禁一个有那么多粉丝的人在技术上其实非常复杂。当你暂停某人时，推特的系统必须弄清楚如何处理所有关注他们的人。而且——
In other words, if you follow Trump, Twitter has to remove him from your list of follows.
换句话说，如果你关注了特朗普，推特必须把他从你的关注列表中移除。
Which sounds very straightforward. But when you have to do that tens of millions of times, immediately-- we had to think about, if we push this button, is the site going to go down?
这听起来很简单。但当你必须立即把这件事做上几千万次时——我们不得不考虑，如果我们按下按钮，网站会不会宕机？
As it turned out, the site stayed up and Trump was banned-- for a while anyway. It was such a strange moment. With the click of a mouse, Twitter had managed to do something that Congress attempted twice and failed-- to punish Donald Trump in a way that had real and immediate consequences for him.
事实证明，网站没宕机，特朗普被封禁了——至少有一段时间是这样。这是一个如此奇怪的时刻。鼠标一点，推特成功做了国会尝试两次却失败的事——以一种对他产生真实且直接后果的方式惩罚唐纳德·特朗普。
Trump headed off to Mar-a-Lago. Yoel got promoted. He was running the whole department. And that's when another mouthy rich guy started to complain about all the rules on Twitter. That guy was Elon Musk.
特朗普前往了海湖庄园。尤尔得到了晋升。他在运营整个部门。就在那时，另一个满嘴脏话的富人开始抱怨推特上的所有规则。那个人是埃隆·马斯克。
In April 2022, Musk announced he'd acquired a big stake in the company. A few days after that, he announced his intention to buy it outright. As soon as the news broke, Yoel's employees started asking what it meant for them. Elon had been tweeting a lot about free speech and his feeling that Twitter didn't have enough of it.
2022年4月，马斯克宣布他收购了公司的大量股份。几天后，他宣布了直接收购的意图。消息传出的那一刻，尤尔的员工就开始问这对他们意味着什么。埃隆一直在推特上谈论言论自由，以及他认为推特没有足够的言论自由。
He posted a photo of six people in dark robes with the caption, "shadow ban council reviewing tweet" and "Truth Social exists because Twitter censored free speech." Also stuff like, "Next, I'm going to buy Coca-Cola and put the cocaine back in," and "Let's make Twitter maximum fun."
他发了一张六个人穿着深色长袍的照片，配文：“影子审查委员会审查推文”和“Truth Social的存在是因为推特审查言论自由”。还有像“接下来，我要买下可口可乐，把可卡因加回去”和“让我们让推特充满乐趣”之类的话。
Some employees working in Trust and Safety worried that "maximum fun" might mean Elon would dismantle their whole operation. Yoel was willing to give him a chance though.
一些在“信任与安全”部门工作的员工担心，“充满乐趣”可能意味着埃隆会解散他们的整个业务。不过尤尔愿意给他一个机会。
What I told them and what I sincerely believed was, it's too soon to tell.
我告诉他们，我也真诚地相信，现在下结论还为时过早。
Yeah.
是的。
People are frequently caricatured and villainized in the media. Certainly, I was. And that's not a reflection of who they actually are. And so don't prejudge.
人们在媒体中经常被刻画和妖魔化。当然，我就是。那并不能反映他们真实的样子。所以不要预先判断。
At the same time, Yoel knew that his more concerned employees might be right, that he was aboard a ship that might be about to sink. He knew he needed to be alert for the signs. His solution was to make a list, to write down the red lines that he would not cross, no matter what. Most days, his job was to enforce other people's rules. But with Elon coming in, he wanted to write down some rules for himself.
与此同时，尤尔知道那些更担心的员工可能是对的，他登上了一艘可能即将沉没的船。他知道自己需要警惕迹象。他的解决方案是列个清单，写下他无论如何都不会跨越的红线。大多数时候，他的工作是执行别人的规则。但随着埃隆的到来，他想为自己写下一些规则。
You have to have written policies and procedures so that when the moment comes to make that decision, you just follow the procedure that you had laid out before.
你必须有书面的政策和程序，这样当做出决定的时刻到来时，你只需遵循之前设定的程序。
Your whole job was about trying to not make decisions out of impulse and emotion, but by following a playbook. And that meant that before Elon took over, you actually had to give yourself a playbook.
你的全部工作就是试图不要凭冲动和情绪做出决定，而是遵循剧本。这意味着在埃隆接管之前，你实际上必须给自己准备一个剧本。
That's right.
没错。
And so on a notepad by his desk, at his house, he wrote down his red lines. "I will not break the law." "I will not lie for him." "I will not undermine the integrity of an election." By the way, if you ever find yourself making a list like this, your job is insane. Then Yoel wrote down one more rule.
于是，在他家里的书桌旁，他在记事本上写下了红线。“我不违法。”“我不为他撒谎。”“我不破坏选举的公正性。”顺便说一句，如果你发现自己做了这样一个清单，你的工作就是疯了。然后尤尔又写下了一条规则。
This was a big one. "I will not take arbitrary or unilateral content-moderation action." And--
这是一条大的。“我不采取随意的或单方面的内容审核行动。”而且——
So if Elon came up to you just said, ban this person, you weren't going to do that?
所以如果埃隆过来只是说“封禁这个人”，你是不打算照做的？
That was the limit.
那就是底线。
Did people on your team show you the lists that they were making too, or talk to you about them?
你团队里的人也向你展示了他们制定的清单，或者和你谈论过吗？
We did.
我们谈过。
Yoel's list of rules got its first test pretty quickly, on the day Elon officially took over Twitter. It was the end of October. Lawyers were finalizing paperwork. And Twitter staff was attempting to enjoy the annual company Halloween party. The scene was surreal.
尤尔的规则清单很快就迎来了第一次考验，就在埃隆正式接管推特的那天。那是10月底。律师们正在敲定文书工作。推特员工正试图享受一年一度的公司万圣节派对。那一幕很超现实。
Were you there for the Halloween party?
你当时在万圣节派对现场吗？
I was.
我在。
Were you dressed up?
你装扮了吗？
I was not.
我没有。
Lots of people did dress up though. Employees brought their kids. There were balloons and face painting. I've talked to so many people who went to this party. And every one of them has added some bizarre new detail. Some people saw a guy dressed as a scarecrow walking around with what appeared to be a handler. They wondered if it was Musk. It turned out to be a hired performer.
不过很多人确实装扮了。员工带着他们的孩子。有气球和脸部彩绘。我采访过很多去过那个派对的人。每个人都添加了一些离奇的新细节。有些人看到一个扮成稻草人的家伙走来走去，身边好像跟着一个经纪人。他们想知道是不是马斯克。结果是一个雇来的表演者。
As the Halloween party had started, I was sitting in a conference room doing some work. And we start hearing rumors that not only has the deal closed, but also the company's executives have been fired. And at first, it's unconfirmed.
万圣节派对开始时，我坐在会议室里处理一些工作。我们开始听到传言，不仅交易已经完成，公司的高管也被解雇了。起初，这并未得到确认。
I get texts from a couple of reporters who asked me, is it true that Vijaya has been fired? And I said, no, I just saw her. She's still online in the company's Slack and Gmail. She's-- of course not. Your sources are lying to you. And then it was true.
我收到几个记者的短信，问我：维贾亚被解雇是真的吗？我说：不，我刚看到她。她还在公司的Slack和Gmail上。她——当然不是。你的消息来源在骗你。然后这是真的。
Such an important lesson-- always trust the reporters. Pretty soon afterward, Yoel gets summoned over to the part of headquarters where Elon and his team had set up shop. He was nervous.
多么重要的一课——永远相信记者。很快，尤尔被叫到了总部埃隆和他的团队建立办公区的地方。他很紧张。
And I thought, OK, I'm about to be fired. So I walk past a number of my employees. And I don't let on that any of this is happening because I don't want to panic them, because they're there with their kids. And so I smile and make jokes about Halloween costumes and walk over to this other part of the office, where somebody who I gather works for Elon Musk in some capacity, but they don't introduce themselves. They just say, how do I get access to Twitter's internal content moderation systems?
我想：好吧，我要被解雇了。于是我走过我的几名员工身边。我没表现出这一切正在发生，因为我不想让他们惊慌，因为他们带着孩子在那儿。所以我笑着开了关于万圣节服装的玩笑，走到办公室的另一边，那里有一个我推测是为埃隆·马斯克工作的人，但他们没介绍自己。他们只是说：我怎么获得推特内部内容审核系统的访问权限？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I pause and blink and say, you don't. That's not going to happen. I explained that Twitter is operating under an FTC consent decree, that access to internal systems is regarded as highly sensitive, and that there are both legal and policy reasons why we simply couldn't grant access to somebody.
我停顿了一下，眨眨眼说：你不会的。那不会发生。我解释说推特是在FTC同意令下运作的，对内部系统的访问被视为高度敏感，而且有法律和政策原因导致我们根本不能授予任何人权限。
Elon's aide explains that they're worried about an insider threat, someone who might try to sabotage the site on their way out. Yoel tells them, sure, I can help with that. He explains some steps they can take to protect the company. And to Yoel's surprise, the aide says, OK, you're going to tell that to Elon. And then he leaves and comes back with Elon Musk.
埃隆的助手解释说，他们担心内部威胁，有人可能在离开时破坏网站。尤尔告诉他们，没问题，我可以提供帮助。他解释了他们可以采取的一些保护公司的措施。令尤尔惊讶的是，助手说：好吧，你要把这个告诉埃隆。然后他离开，带回了埃隆·马斯克。
Who, at this point, I've seen on the internet, but I had not met in person. And so Elon sits down and asks, well, let me see our tools. "Our" tools-- he owns the company at this point. And so I show him his own account in Twitter's set of enforcement tools. And I explain to him what the basic capabilities are. And then I make a recommendation to him of what I think Twitter should do to prevent insider misuse of tools during the corporate transition.
在那之前，我在互联网上见过他，但没见过真人。于是埃隆坐下来问：好吧，让我看看我们的工具。“我们的”工具——此刻他拥有这家公司。于是我向他展示了他在推特执行工具集里的个人账户。我向他解释了基本功能是什么。然后我向他提出了建议，关于我认为推特应该做什么来防止在企业过渡期间滥用内部工具。
Yoel also had recommendations about the midterms and the upcoming presidential election in Brazil.
尤尔还对中期选举和即将到来的巴西总统选举提出了建议。
And as I start to explain some of the rationale related to the Brazilian election, Elon interrupts me and says, yes, Brazil. Bolsonaro and Lula are very dangerous. We need to protect that.
当我开始解释与巴西选举相关的一些逻辑时，埃隆打断我说：是的，巴西。博索纳罗和卢拉非常危险。我们需要保护这一点。
And I was floored. I came into that conversation expecting him to fire me, and instead, he jumps ahead of me to say that he is sensitive to the risks of offline violence in the context of the Brazilian election and wants to make sure that we don't interrupt Twitter's content-moderation capabilities. It was like a dream come true.
我当时惊呆了。我走进那场谈话时以为他会解雇我，结果他反而在我之前就说他对巴西选举背景下线下暴力的风险很敏感，并想确保我们不会干扰推特的内容审核能力。那就像梦想成真。
You're thinking, maybe I'm actually aligned with this person.
你当时在想：也许我和这个人是一致的。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
And so Yoel stayed. He was surprised in a good way. On Twitter, Elon talked about the company as if it should barely have any rules at all. But in that moment, one on one, Yoel thought he might turn out to be more reasonable. Maybe spending some time inside the company would show Elon the real value of those rules, which is that, without them, you lose your users and you lose your advertisers.
于是尤尔留下了。他惊喜地发现情况不错。在推特上，埃隆谈论公司时就像它几乎不应该有任何规则一样。但在那一刻，一对一的时候，尤尔觉得他可能是一个更理智的人。也许花点时间在公司内部会向埃隆展示这些规则的真正价值，那就是：没有它们，你就会失去用户和广告商。
And Yoel felt like Elon could be sensible. One of his first requests was to restore the account of The Babylon Bee, a right-wing satire site. But Yoel explained how it had broken Twitter's rules and Elon backed off.
尤尔觉得埃隆可能是个明理的人。他最早的要求之一是恢复《巴比伦蜜蜂》的账户，一个右翼讽刺网站。但尤尔解释了它是如何违反推特规则的，埃隆退让了。
I found him to be funny. I found him to be reasonable. I found that he responded well to having evidence-backed recommendations be put in front of him. And I, for a moment, felt that it might be possible for Twitter's Trust and Safety work to not just continue, but also to get better.
我发现他很有趣。我发现他很理智。我发现他能很好地响应那些有证据支持的建议。我有一瞬间觉得，推特的“信任与安全”工作不仅可能继续，而且可能做得更好。
After that, things began to move really quickly. About a week later, Elon laid off half the staff. Suddenly, Yoel was one of the highest-ranking employees from the old Twitter who was still working at the new one. And it seemed like Elon liked him. After some trolls went after Yoel for some of his old tweets, Elon tweeted that he supported him.
之后，事情开始飞速发展。大约一周后，埃隆解雇了一半员工。突然，尤尔成了还在新推特工作的老推特高管之一。埃隆似乎很喜欢他。在一些喷子因为尤尔过去的一些推文而攻击他后，埃隆发推文表示支持他。
The US midterm elections took place mostly without incident, same for the election in Brazil. Elon kept pushing his teams to move faster, even as he was laying them off. At first, Yoel said that Twitter still had enough content moderators to keep the site safe. But the cuts kept coming and the work got harder and harder.
美国中期选举基本没发生什么事故，巴西选举也是如此。埃隆不断催促他的团队加快行动，尽管他一直在解雇他们。起初，尤尔说推特还有足够的内容审核员来保持网站安全。但裁员持续不断，工作变得越来越难。
Soon, Elon unveiled his first big idea for making lots of money and recouping the $44 billion he had spent to buy the company. Yoel and his team thought it was insane. The plan-- to let anyone get a blue "verified" badge for their profile for $8 a month. The company called it Twitter Blue.
很快，埃隆公布了他赚钱并收回为收购公司花费的440亿美元的第一个重大想法。尤尔和他的团队认为这简直疯了。计划是——让任何人每月支付8美元就能获得蓝色的“认证”徽章。公司称之为“推特蓝”。
The risks seemed obvious. People would just make new accounts to impersonate brands and politicians and other celebrities. Yoel and his team wrote a seven-page document outlining the risks. But the badges went on sale anyway. And almost immediately, impersonators started buying them and wreaking havoc.
风险看起来显而易见。人们会创建新账户来冒充品牌、政客和其他名人。尤尔和他的团队写了一份七页的文件概述风险。但徽章还是上线了。几乎立刻，冒充者就开始购买它们并大肆破坏。
In maybe the most famous case, someone impersonated the drug maker Eli Lilly and said that insulin would now be free. The real Eli Lilly's stock price dropped more than 5%. It was a vivid illustration of why companies like Twitter make rules in the first place. Impersonators were suddenly all over the site.
在也许最著名的案例中，有人冒充药物制造商礼来公司，并声称胰岛素现在将免费。真正的礼来公司的股价下跌了5%以上。这是一个鲜活的例证，说明了为什么像推特这样的公司一开始就要制定规则。冒充者突然遍布整个网站。
And so, OK, we have to ban them. But somebody has to review them. We can't just ban everyone. And so you do that with content moderators. And we had instructions to fire more of our contract content moderation staff to cut costs.
好吧，我们必须封禁他们。但得有人审查他们。我们不能只是封禁所有人。所以你要用内容审核员去做。我们当时收到的指令是解雇更多的合同内容审核人员来削减成本。
All of this seems really self-evident to me. And I think it would have seemed self-evident even before you launched this. But what was Elon's take on this? How did he respond to you raising these concerns?
这一切对我来说似乎非常不言自明。而且我想即使在推出这个之前，它看起来也应该不言自明。但埃隆对此有何看法？当你提出这些担忧时，他有何回应？
Do it anyway. And that was a breaking point for me.
“无论如何都要去做。”这成了我的一个转折点。
We reached out to Twitter for comment but didn't hear back. Reporters have sometimes gotten automated poop emojis, but I didn't even get that.
我们联系推特评论，但没得到回应。记者们有时会得到自动回复的便便表情符号，但我甚至没得到那个。
Yoel had spent a long time gaming out scenarios for what might make him leave Twitter. He made that whole list. He wouldn't break the law for Elon. He wouldn't undermine an election. But ultimately what got to him was something he didn't foresee. It wasn't on the list. It was something more personal. He knew this bizarre plan wouldn't just make people lose trust in Twitter. They would lose trust in him.
尤尔花了很长时间规划他离开推特的情景。他列了那个清单。他不会为了埃隆违法。他不会破坏选举。但最终让他下定决心的是他没预见到的事情。它不在清单上。那是更个人的事。他知道这个古怪的计划不仅会让人们失去对推特的信任。他们会失去对他的信任。
Behind Elon Musk, I was the most prominent representative of the company, period. And I became aware that when Twitter Blue turned into the predictable hot mess that it was, that people would ask, why didn't the Trust and Safety team see this coming? Yoel, why are you so bad at your job?
在埃隆·马斯克之后，我是公司最著名的代表，没别的。我意识到，当“推特蓝”变成那种可预测的烂摊子时，人们会问：为什么“信任与安全”团队没预见到这一点？尤尔，为什么你的工作做得这么差？
The day after the launch, Yoel and Elon got on the phone. Elon thought the problem could be fixed if Apple would just hand over all the credit card information of the people doing the impersonations. Yoel had to explain that Apple would never do that. He also asked Elon to slow down the rollout of Blue so that they would have time to hire and train more content moderators to look for impersonators. Elon didn't understand why that would take longer than a day.
发布后的第二天，尤尔和埃隆通了电话。埃隆认为如果苹果公司交出那些冒充者人的所有信用卡信息，问题就能解决。尤尔不得不解释苹果永远不会那样做。他还要求埃隆放慢“推特蓝”的推广速度，以便他们有时间雇佣和培训更多内容审核员来寻找冒充者。埃隆不明白为什么那会超过一天。
I got off that phone call and thought, I can't solve this problem. I will spend the rest of my time at this company trying to bail out a ship that might sink more slowly because I'm there, bailing it out. But I don't want to spend the rest of my life bailing out a sinking ship.
我放下那通电话，心想：我解决不了这个问题。我会把余生花在这家公司，试图舀干一艘可能因为我在那里舀水而沉得更慢的船。但我不想把余生花在舀干一艘下沉的船上。
Yoel had made up his mind to leave. He called a couple of his employees to let them know.
尤尔决定离开。他给他的几名员工打了电话告诉他们。
I knew that that day, I did not want to be walked out of Twitter, after almost eight years, by corporate security. I wanted to leave on my own terms. And there was an all-hands going on at the time, Elon's first time addressing the company in person. And during that all-hands meeting, I hit send on my resignation email, put my laptop in my bag, and walked out of the building for the last time.
我知道那天我不希望在待了近八年后，被企业保安从推特带走。我想按自己的方式离开。当时正在进行全员会议，埃隆第一次亲自向公司发表讲话。在那次全员会议期间，我点击发送了辞职邮件，把笔记本电脑放进包里，最后一次走出了大楼。
Did you purposefully send it when you knew he was on stage?
你是故意在他上台时发送的吗？
Yes, absolutely.
是的，绝对。
Mm.
嗯。
I knew that it would take some time for the HR team to see it and process it, for that to get to him, for him to react to it. And in that time, I knew I wanted to be back at home and not be in the office.
我知道人力资源团队需要一些时间才能看到并处理它，才能传达给他，才能让他做出反应。在那段时间里，我知道我想回家，而不是留在办公室。
Was it a long email?
那是一封长信吗？
It was one sentence.
只有一句话。
What was the sentence?
那句话是什么？
"I am no longer able to perform the responsibilities of my job and resign it as of today at 5:00 PM." I remember feeling two things. On one hand, I felt relieved. And then I also just felt deeply sad. I just wanted to get home.
“我无法再履行我的工作职责，并于今天下午5点辞职。”我记得感觉到了两件事。一方面，我感到解脱。另一方面，我感到深深的悲伤。我只想回家。
So I left Twitter's garage and was driving. And I was about halfway across the Bay Bridge when I think Zoe broke the news that I left Twitter, and my phone exploded. And I get--
我离开了推特的车库，正在开车。我快到海湾大桥的一半时，我想佐伊发布了我离开推特的新闻，我的手机炸开了锅。我——
Wait. You didn't even get across the bridge before Zoe broke the news? God, I love her.
等等。你甚至没过桥，佐伊就发布了新闻？天哪，我爱死她了。
Zoe is my coworker. I am immensely proud of her, even if she did kind of mess up Yoel's plans. The car Yoel was driving that day was a Tesla, by the way. He was leasing it. He'd been trying to return it but couldn't get anyone to respond to him. Maybe they'd all been drafted to work at Twitter.
佐伊是我的同事。我对她无比自豪，即使她搞砸了尤尔的计划。顺便说一句，尤尔那天开的车是一辆特斯拉。他租的。他一直在试着退还它，但没人理他。也许他们都被拉去推特工作了。
Yoel laid low for a few days. He spent some time writing, and published an op-ed in The New York Times. It explained, in a very dry and principled way, why he'd left. That's when some rando account reshared something Yoel had tweeted from 2010 about relationships between adults and minors. Around that time, he'd been working on his dissertation, which called for tech companies to do more to protect minors at gay hookup sites like Grindr.
尤尔躲了几天。他花了一些时间写作，并在《纽约时报》发表了一篇观点文章。文章用一种非常干练和原则性的方式解释了他为什么离开。那时，某个随机账户分享了尤尔在2010年发的一条关于成人与未成年人关系的推文。大约在那时，他正在做他的论文，号召科技公司采取更多措施保护像Grindr这样的同性恋交友网站上的未成年人。
But Elon replied with a tweet, quote, "This explains a lot." Then he linked to Yoel's dissertation. Quote, "Looks like Yoel is arguing in favor of children being able to access adult internet services in his PhD thesis." Not true. But Yoel's phone exploded with abusive messages. It made the backlash to labeling a Trump tweet look minor by comparison.
但埃隆回复了一条推文，引文：“这解释了很多。”然后他链接到尤尔的论文。引文：“看起来尤尔在他的博士论文中主张儿童应该能够访问成人互联网服务。”这不是真的。但尤尔的手机被辱骂信息炸开了锅。这让给特朗普推文打标签的反弹显得微不足道。
Hundreds of messages per hour, homophobic, anti-Semitic, and also violent, just deeply, endlessly violent. And he only had to tweet once. He didn't even have to say directly, Yoel is a pedophile. He just had to wink and nod in that direction. And people took his lead.
每小时数百条信息，恐同、反犹，还有暴力，深深的、无尽的暴力。他只需要发一条推文。他甚至不需要直接说“尤尔是恋童癖”。他只需要在那方向上眨眨眼，点点头。人们就听从了他的引导。
When Yoel had first used the internet, it felt like a small, self-contained space, separate from what we used to call real life. But by the time Yoel quit Twitter, the distinction between online and off had collapsed. And it had collapsed, in large part, because of the company he worked at, Twitter.
当尤尔第一次使用互联网时，它感觉像是一个小的、自给自足的空间，与我们过去称之为现实生活的东西分开。但当尤尔从推特辞职时，在线与离线之间的界限已经崩溃。而且这种崩溃在很大程度上是因为他工作的那家公司——推特。
The site brought together so many of the world's most influential people and then pitted them against each other in these all-consuming daily battles. And the anger coming out of that could drive people to do things, violent things. Pretty soon, Yoel and his husband were overwhelmed with death threats.
该网站聚集了世界上许多最具影响力的人，然后让他们在这些消耗心力的日常战斗中互相对抗。从中产生的愤怒可能会驱使人们做些事，暴力的事情。很快，尤尔和他的丈夫就被死亡威胁淹没了。
My husband turned to me one day and said, I've seen you through a lot of being targeted and being harassed. I've never seen you look scared before. And that was the moment that we decided to leave our home.
我丈夫有一天转过身对我说：我看着你经历了这么多被针对和骚扰。但我从没见过你看起来害怕过。那一刻，我们决定离开我们的家。
And so once again, they moved. I met with Yoel at the temporary house that he and his husband are staying at while they look for a new place. After all this, I thought Yoel might want a different kind of job. I would have wanted a different kind of job. The internet had almost killed him, or threatened to anyway. But still, somehow, he's optimistic about what the internet could be in a way you almost never hear anymore.
所以他们再次搬家了。我和尤尔在他和丈夫寻找新住处时暂住的房子里见面。经历了这一切，我以为尤尔会想要一份不同的工作。我会想要一份不同的工作。互联网差点杀了他，或者至少威胁到了他。但尽管如此，不知何故，他依然对互联网的未来充满乐观，这种乐观是你几乎再也听不到的了。
I love the internet. I really do. I think-- the internet's power to bring people together and help folks all over the world find connections that matter to them is magical and is one of humanity's greatest achievements.
我爱互联网。我真的爱。我认为——互联网将人们聚集在一起，帮助全世界的人们找到对他们重要的联系的力量是神奇的，是人类最伟大的成就之一。
I also think the internet can be incredibly dangerous and scary. And the work of Trust and Safety is trying to push that back a little bit and to make the internet more of what it can be and less of the dangers of what it could turn into.
我也认为互联网可以极其危险和可怕。而“信任与安全”的工作就是试图稍微抵制那种危险，让互联网更多地成为它可能成为的样子，而不是它可能变成的危险。
Yoel's idealism about the internet feels radical, given how destabilizing it's been, how destabilizing Twitter has been. But I know what he means. Back when he was a teenager, the internet gave Yoel a place to discover other gay people, the chance to talk to everyone in the world instantaneously. It gave him a career. It gave me all those things too. I remember life before the internet. It was a less frantic time. But it was also a lonelier one.
尤尔对互联网的理想主义感觉很激进，考虑到它已经变得多么不稳定，考虑到推特已经变得多么不稳定。但我知道他是什么意思。当他还是个少年时，互联网给了尤尔一个发现其他同性恋者的地方，一个与全世界所有人即时交谈的机会。它给了他一份职业。它也给了我所有那些东西。我记得互联网时代之前的生活。那是一个不那么疯狂的时代。但它也是一个更孤独的时代。
Here's how Twitter is doing since Yoel left. Hate speech is on the rise. Advertisers have fled. Banks that funded Musk's takeover have marked their investments down by more than half. Musk himself has warned repeatedly that the site might go bankrupt. I kind of hope it does. Because what's happening at Twitter right now is teaching us a lesson it's taken us way too long to learn-- that people like Yoel, they're not the enemies of free speech online. They're the ones who make it possible.
这是自尤尔离开后推特的状况。仇恨言论在增加。广告商已经逃离。资助马斯克收购的银行已经将其投资减记了一半以上。马斯克本人也多次警告该网站可能会破产。我倒有点希望它破产。因为推特现在发生的事情正在给我们上一门我们花了太久才学到的课——像尤尔这样的人，他们不是互联网言论自由的敌人。他们是让它成为可能的人。
If you get any value out of social media at all, it's in part because of them. They clean the place up, make it feel good to be there. They pull us back when we go too far. And they do censor us. And of course we hate them for it. We convince ourselves we'd do a much better job if it were us. That's what Elon thought. Look what happened.
如果你从社交媒体上得到了任何价值，那部分归功于他们。他们清理了这个地方，让在那里感觉良好。当我们走得太远时，他们拉住我们。他们确实审查我们。我们当然为此讨厌他们。我们说服自己如果是我们，会做得好得多。埃隆就是这么想的。看看发生了什么。
Nobody likes the guy enforcing the rules. But watching Twitter sink into the ocean, you can't help but notice how much you miss that guy when he's gone.
没人喜欢执行规则的家伙。但看着推特沉入海洋，你无法不注意到当那个家伙消失时，你是多么想念他。
Casey Newton. He's the co-host of the podcast Hard Fork, from The New York Times, who are our collaborators on this. He also writes the newsletter Platformer. His story was produced by David Kestenbaum and Davis Land.
凯西·牛顿。他是来自《纽约时报》的播客《Hard Fork》的联合主持人，他们是我们的合作伙伴。他还撰写时事通讯《Platformer》。他的故事由大卫·克滕鲍姆和戴维斯·兰德制作。
(SINGING) Listen up, children, and give your respect to this tale of a captain in another cursed wreck. Elon was his name, commandeering his game. He took over the ship, seeking only more fame. For his rockets and cars, he had tons of acclaim. But Elon wanted more and it ended in shame. Whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh, Elon wanted more and it ended in shame.
（歌唱）听好了，孩子们，向这个关于在另一场被诅咒的沉船中的船长的故事致敬。埃隆是他的名字，统领着他的游戏。他接管了船，只为了寻求更多的名声。对于他的火箭和汽车，他有着无数的赞誉。但埃隆想要更多，结局却在羞愧中。喔，噢，噢，噢，噢，埃隆想要更多，结局却在羞愧中。
He dragged all the watchmen out from their crow's nests and forced them to walk down the plank to their rest, leaving no one to look out, no one who knew best. The ship fell apart in a watery mess. Whoa, oh, oh, oh, the ship fell apart in a watery mess.
他把所有守望者从他们的瞭望塔上拖走，强迫他们走下木板去休息，留下没人看守，没人在意。船在混乱的水中分崩离析。喔，噢，噢，噢，船在混乱的水中分崩离析。
Our program was produced by Sean Cole with Zoe Chace. The people who put together today's show include Michal Comite, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Bethel Habte, Valerie Kipnis, Alaa Mustafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Charlotte Sleeper, Alix Spiegel, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目由肖恩·科尔和佐伊·蔡斯制作。今天节目的幕后人员包括米哈尔·科米特，安德烈娅·洛佩兹·克鲁萨多，阿维娃·德科恩费尔德，伯特利·哈布特，瓦莱丽·基普尼斯，阿拉·穆斯塔法，斯托·尼尔森，凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多，纳迪亚·雷曼，夏洛特·斯里珀，阿利克斯·斯皮格尔，弗朗西斯·斯旺森，克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉，马特·蒂尔尼，朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Kendra Stanton Lee, Devin Pacholik, Emma Laz-Hirsch, Shawn Allee, Jeremy Butman, Imran Ahmed, and the Sea Tow captain who rescued the Marjorie and spoke with Ike, who would like to remain unnamed.
我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，我们的资深编辑是大卫·克滕鲍姆。我们的执行总监是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢肯德拉·斯坦顿·李，德文·帕乔利克，艾玛·拉兹-赫希，肖恩·艾利，杰里米·布特曼，伊姆兰·艾哈迈德，以及那位营救了“玛乔丽号”并与艾克交谈过、不愿透露姓名的Sea Tow船长。
Our second sea shanty in today's show was also written by Samson the Truest, Sam Geller, strings and engineering by Jesse Kotansky. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's a list of favorite shows if you're looking for something to listen to, all kinds of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
今天节目中的第二首海员号子也是由“最真实的萨姆森”萨姆·盖勒创作的，弦乐和工程由杰西·科坦斯基完成。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过750集的档案。如果你想找点什么听听，还有一个最爱节目列表，那里还有各种其他内容。再次提醒，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he and Kendall and Roman and Shiv were in the deep end of the pool. They were struggling. They were nearly drowning until Torey looked up and realized--
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他和肯德尔、罗曼和希夫在游泳池的深水区。他们挣扎着。他们差点溺水，直到托里抬头意识到——
Look, it's so close. We can just swim to Logan.
你看，离得那么近。我们可以直接游到洛根机场。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
(SINGING) Whoa, oh, oh, oh, put a bow on this sinking show. Whoa, oh, oh, oh, put a bow on this sinking show.
（歌唱）喔，噢，噢，噢，给这场沉没的节目打个结。喔，噢，噢，噢，给这场沉没的节目打个结。